phonemen diagrams are very useful
because they take the complicated and
abstract mathematics of particle
interactions
and show the equations as simple
pictures of what happens when subatomic
particles interact
the axes of feynman diagrams are space
and time and the different particles get
different lines
a photon is a wiggle the gluons are
spirals the w
and z bosons and the higgs boson get a
dotted line and the fermions get
straight lines with arrows
these arrows point forwards in time for
mata particles and backwards in time for
antimatter
particles and the arrows always flow
from one side of the diagram to the
other
the building blocks of feynman diagrams
are vertices which are a joining point
between
three particles the orientation of these
vertices changes the story they're
telling
this one shows an electron changing
momentum when it emits a photon
but if you rotate it it shows an
electron and positron annihilation into
a photon
you can build most fundament diagrams
from this set of vertices
like this or this if you want more
information check out my full video in
the description